hi my name is James Jolla key i'm the
product manager for text plus i manage
the ios and android engineering teams
and also participated in the new design
of our android application textplus is a
free texting and calling application
that allows you to text for free
anywhere in the United States and Canada
because at the end of the day that's
what textplus is it really it's a way
for you to send your emotions to your
friends and family in the people that
you love so one of the things I like
best about Google Play is the reply to
review feature as a product manager and
someone who runs the the client team
it's been a great Avenue for me to one
be able to talk to our users but also
incorporate their feedback into the
application whether that is features or
whether that's bugs anything to give me
more information to do my job better the
replied reviews feature has essentially
given me that direct line that I didn't
have before something else that's really
critical to user reviews is we make our
engineering teams actually spend time
looking through and even replying to the
reviews at times it really allows the
team to see what the user saying about
the product they spend all of their time
building and we really feel it gives an
extra initiative to improve the product
so that's something we we love doing and
will do it you know once a week or every
other week it really just gives the
engineers insight into you know what the
users are saying and also something the
replies reviews has helped us manage
we've essentially you know since we've
had access to this feature we've
increased you know daily installs by
roughly forty percent so it's really key
to us to maintain our overall rating so
this has allowed us to you know monitor
the monitor the reviews and respond to
customer concerns quickly and provide
feedback if they're having an issue that
we can immediately resolve the user from
this is a perfect example of user
feedback being incorporated into the
roadmap so something that we see in the
review is almost daily is
personalization so I mean sometimes it's
tough being designer you want things to
look at
specific way and you're very like
particular about I want this background
I want this asset but we've seen it over
and over again the users have said I
want customization I want to make
textplus look I want it to look so
something that is coming very soon and
very quickly is the ability for users to
customize the look and feel the app so
essentially they will be able to change
the background change the chat bubble
color change the accent color so it's
truly you know giving the users
something they want entirely based on
feedback that we saw in the reviews so
in Google Play textplus continues to do
very well it's actually completely
shifting our business to more Android
first and we've you know increase our
daily installs roughly forty percent
since August so we're continuing to move
in a very positive direction on Google
Play
you